the campaigns for presidential elections
in uganda haven't been peaceful
police and soldiers have blocked
political opposition candidates on the
roads
it's all been live streamed by online
tvs
like this channel on youtube the
government's now written to youtube's
owner
google asking it to block 14 of the
channels
accusing them of inciting violence no
accusations have been put before a court
of law against the managers
of these platforms so government is
simply writing to google
as a means of intimidating these
managers of these youtube channels
and platforms as an attempt a continued
attempt
to strive for the political position
all of the 14 channels are linked to pop
star
turned presidential candidate bobby wine
his supporters are young they're at home
online
and the platforms provide an opening for
opposition in a country
where the government controls access to
much of the traditional media
dozens of people were killed when police
violently broke up demonstrators last
month
it followed the arrest of bobby wine
police said his rallies broke
covid rules opposition and rights groups
say the government doesn't want ugandans
or the world
to see what's happening police since
announced that all journalists had to be
vetted
to be able to cover the elections this
will give a very clear distinction
between genuine journalists and those
that are in genuine
and also help eliminate the propagation
of rumors
disinformation antagonistic discussions
which are likely to incite violence
violence is something that journalists
say they've suffered at the hands of the
police
this cameraman was shot in the face with
a rubber bullet
this reporter is among a group who say
they were beaten
by police last week police say they're
investigating
press groups say the government's now
trying to prevent foreign journalists
from coming to cover the polls lots of
journalists that wanted to come into
uganda to cover this election
and what we've seen is is that many of
those journalists who have applied for
accreditation
have been left waiting for days or weeks
for that accreditation to be processed
in some cases journalists who have
entered the country have even been
deported
the government blocked social media
services during the last election
google has said governments have to
submit court orders
for youtube channels to be removed so
for now the online tvs
keep streaming malcolm webb al jazeera